ja liebe Zuseherin das Thema was mir
besonders am Herzen liegt sind die
kleinen Kulturbetriebe Theater Kinos die
sind ja alle wieder offen Gott sei Dank
und haben momentan auch keine
Restriktion aber trotzdem kommen zu
wenig Leute zu wenig Leute gehen ins
Theater es gibt hier zum Beispiel
Berliner Wedding das Primetime tolles
kieztheater bei mir in München das
Backstage einen tollen Club aber die
Leute gehen noch nicht hin manche haben
Angst verstehe ich aber ich möchte es
einfach mal appellieren auch an sie
nutzen sie wieder die kulturellen
Gelegenheiten auch in ländlichen
Regionen die ist so viel gibt weil das
sind so viele Leute mit Herzblut
unterwegs die was leisten die brauchen
jetzt auch wieder Publikum und ich habe
auch eine Bitte an meine eigene
Bundesregierung als Parlament bitte
schafft für diesen Winter keine Regeln
die die Geschäftsmodelle dieser
Unternehmen wieder so einschränken dass
nichts geht das geht übrigens auch
vermessen für Veranstaltungswirtschaft
also gibt den kleinen wieder eine Chance
weil die haben tolles angeboten wir
müssen das den wieder helfen dass das
klappt mit dem kann man ja nur hoffen
dass es Karl Lauterbach heute abend 8:15
Uhr zu Gast aber als ich eben gerade
diesen diesen diese Bilder gesehen habe
habe ich mich erinnert wie viele künst
eigentlich auch ein Aufschrei gemacht
haben während der ganzen Maßnahmen und
die wurden ja teilweise also zum
Beispiel bei Jan Josef Liefers wurde
sogar gefordert dass er kein Tatort
Kommissar mehr ist und das sogar von
einem öffentlich-rechtlichen
Journalisten wie schlimm glauben Sie
denn rückblickend war es dass die
Künstler nicht mehr gehört wurden dass
die Regierung nicht sich mehr mit den
Künstlern zusammengesetzt hat also bei
den Künstlern gab es auch
unterschiedliche Meinungen wie man mit
der Pandemie umzugehen hat aber
insgesamt war das Meinungsklima in
Deutschland in der Pandemie ich sag's
mal ganz deutlich unterirdisch in vielen
Bereichen Menschen die einzelnen
Maßnahmen kritisiert haben und ich rede
jetzt nicht von Leuten die sagen es gibt
kein Corona oder es gibt Impfstoff der
ist doof oder so also einzelne Maßnahmen
die wurden dann auch gleich in die
querdecker-ecke gesteckt und so und das
war nicht in Ordnung
wieder aufzumachen noch 150 Tagen
ist das ja ganz normal wobei mich das
mittlerweile überhaupt nicht beeindruckt
mehr aber es ist trotzdem hart gewesen
dass Menschen wie gesagt haben wir
wollen wieder kulturelles Leben haben
gerne auch indem wir eigene Maßnahmen
Hygienemaßnahmen machen ob die jetzt gut
sind oder nicht und die haben das
versucht und wurden dann immer sehr
schnell in der Ecke gestellt das war
nicht gut und aktuell sind die immer
noch ganz viel Konzerte wo wenig Tickets
verkauft werden deswegen haben ihre
teesorteamt gibt es denn irgendein
Lösungsvorschlag den sie haben außerhalb
dieses Appells das eine ist schon dass
wir jetzt keine neuen
kapazitätsobergrenzen für den Winter
schaffen weil wenn Sie jetzt das
Einkaufszentrum offen halten und laufen
15.000 Leute durch am Tag und auf der
anderen Seite muss dann die Messe planen
und weiß nicht was sie planen muss dann
macht die keine Messe ja und so ist es
eben bei den Theatern auch wenn die
heute schon wissen ab Oktober gibt es
sozusagen auf jeden Fall maskenpflicht
im Theater und Abstand dann ist zu sagen
das Geschäft am Ende ja und da müssen
wir auf Eigenverantwortung setzen ich
habe da überhaupt kein Problem wenn
Leute sagen sie wollen sich schützen mit
einer Maske finde ich super aber wenn
sie es nicht wollen dann ist es auch
super und zu dem Zustand müssen wir
jetzt hinkommen ja wie sieht das
politisch aus wie wahrscheinlich ist es
das doch Maske beispielsweise eine Oper
oder auch die oberbegrenzung wenn du
Karl Lauterbach wie heute in der
Pressekonferenz dazu gehört hast also es
halte ich für durchaus realistisch ob
ich das gut finde ist eine andere Frage
und ich glaube der Appell den sie da
gemacht haben der ist dringend den
müssten sie aber wahrscheinlich
vielleicht auch in einem Brandbrief oder
einem Brand Aufruf über Social Media wie
auch immer gerne auch nachts weil Karl
Lauterbach ja auch nachts wach ist wie
wir alle wissen und auch Twitter liest
aber direkt glaube ich an den
Bundesgesundheitsminister errichten denn
der hat natürlich heute auch in seiner
Pressekonferenz einmal mehr vor einem
ganz ganz schlimmen Herbst gewahrt also
der hat einen ein Bild gezeichnet dass
er ja schon seit Wochen seit Monaten
muss man fast sagen zeichnet und hat
eigentlich
neue Untergangsszenarien skizziert
interessant sie haben das ja auch eine
vor Beginn der Sendung kurz gesagt wenn
man den Liberalen Marco Buschmann
daneben gehabt gesehen hat als
Justizminister dachte man die Reden über
zwei verschiedene Dinge weil der
versucht als runterzudecken aber
Lauterbach hat selbst gesagt wir haben
die Maßnahmen noch mal verschärft und
das führt natürlich zu einem Klima das
was sie auch gerade Ansprachen das
wahrscheinlich viele Menschen wieder
sagen Gottes Willen um Gottes Willen
nicht nur in Schulen sondern auch für
Menschen die gerne in Kulturbetriebe
gehen oder auf Messen auf in Theater in
Kinos können wir uns das eigentlich noch
zumuten ist das nicht alles wieder viel
zu gefährlich deswegen meine mein Rat
vielleicht wenn ich das überhaupt sagen
darf an sie twittert sie nachts jetzt
heute Nacht alles machen
sie müssen das ihn glaube ich direkt
einmal gucken aber antwortet aber wie
ist denn das Standing von Karl
Lauterbach zum Beispiel ihrer Partei ist
es noch ein sicherer Gesundheitsminister
der sicher sitzt oder wird es schon
immer lauter dass man sagt also langsam
kann man es nicht mehr tragen nee der
hat ja auch viele Fans also ist ja auch
okay der hat ja auch vieles durchaus
auch geleistet indem er frühzeitig
gewarnt hat die Frage ist ob man
irgendwann wieder rauskommt aus dem
Modus also insofern
nee ich bin nicht so ein Fan seiner
Kommunikation respektiere dass er mit
einem guten ansinn unterwegs ist und
dass er auch viel weiß aber was mir
nicht gefällt ist dass man heute
systematisch auch ein Stück weit
verängstigt und zwar mit so Sachen dass
man dann sagt da kommt jetzt der Killer
Virus dann kommt ja nicht und jetzt
kommt dann wieder immer das Schlimmste
und wenn immer das Schlimmste kommt dann
tut das der Seele weh den Menschen und
das ist auch gefährlich also die
psychische Seite der Pandemie die ist
vernachlässigt die psychische also zum
Beispiel Karl Lauterbach hat ja heute
auch die Impfstoffe die dann auch vor
Infektionen schützen werden Stör macht
sich lustig darüber wenn man das so
plump formulieren kann ist es nicht auch
langsam aus medizinischer Sicht so sie
sind jetzt kein Arzt was man sich schon
als Bürger sind ja auch Bürger mal fragt
ob das alles noch so viel Sinn macht
ich bin immer bei der Ständigen
Impfkommission die wurde ja auch stark
angegriffen ich fand das immer gut dass
sie sich auch die Zeit genommen haben
diese gebraucht haben selbst wenn der
Druck hoch war und die haben die
Empfehlungen zu geben und danach impfe
ich mich deswegen bin ich jetzt dreimal
geimpft ich bin nicht 60 Jahre alt wenn
ich 60 wäre würde ich mich aus viermal
impfen
ich würde zum Beispiel auch sagen dass
die Kultureinrichtungen auch eine
Relevanz dahingehend haben dass die
Menschen das auch einfach für Ihre
mentale Gesundheit brauchen und auch
sich mal wieder so ein bisschen zu
trauen in Interaktion zu begeben in den
Austausch zu gehen ich glaube
da merkt man halt andere Folgen der
Pandemie jetzt nicht im gesundheitlichen
sondern eben dass das auch was mit
unseren miteinander macht und ich habe
zum Beispiel auch regelmäßig Austausch
mit meinen Kundinnen und Kunden und man
merkt schon dass das bei allen Spuren
hinterlassen hat und da würde ich ich
hatte auch mal Zeit lang im
Kulturbetrieb gearbeitet und würde auch
sagen dass das wichtig ist für unser
gesellschaftliches Miteinander und
deswegen denke ich jetzt das schon wenn
wir konkret zu Ihnen kommen sie haben
einen Friseursalon sie sind
friseurhandwerksmeisterin die Frage ist
jetzt natürlich die ich mir stelle wie
ging es ihnen psychisch während der
lockdowns und wenn sie jetzt daran
denken dass sie vielleicht wieder
schließen müssen